i've never been checked so hard in my
life this guy's like four years older
than me by the way i'm a freshman i'm 14
at the time i got i specifically
remember it was the coke slushie i got
that [__] right here filled it up to the
top this dude standing in front of me is
like give me your coke
and i'm like
who are you yeah
i'm like no and i'm moving past this
fool i [__] you not slaps me
in my face this little 13 year old fat
korean kid
i don't know why he just slaps me right
wow and i look at him
i start tearing up i'm like oh god
oh my god
oh [__]
five
four
three
two [__] one there's three cameras i
don't even know where to look at this is
like a weird energy hey everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast this is a new location
that we're trying out we don't know if
it's gonna stick but i think it looks
[__] good yeah i think it's fantastic
it looks great we have two very special
dumbass guests here
we got nick the ear
laker boy like a boy dark skinned south
east asian bang penis is darker than his
face for sack the same colors as nipples
i hear no lies bro this guy's five for
five right now at the gate and then of
course we have patrick dot t dot riley
the t stands for tomas in case you guys
don't know he's [__] mexican bro
all day what about the color don't leave
your catalytic converters available
he's stealing all of them
he's getting the [__] copper inside
that's his hustle bro
besides
my white ass
welcome to 20 20 22 baby yeah that's a
lot of 20. so that's too many that's the
last one
20 20 20 22 and the world is [__]
crumbling everybody is dying yeah uh
what's it called so true
has no heart yeah rgb
betty white passed away yeah did you
guys love betty white i liked her i mean
i she was cool as [__] but i don't i
didn't know enough about her every time
i saw her she was one of those people
that made me happy every time i saw her
i didn't know anything about her but i
was like damn betty weiss here like dope
betty white you know what's [__] up so
i guess they already had this whole
series of them uh i think it was like
people's magazine was going to celebrate
her
turning into a 100 yeah so i went to go
watch spiderman
the the movie and they had a commercial
for saying come celebrate with me on my
100th birthday anyway she already passed
away oh she had died but they were
already rolling the ads in the theaters
oh no she passed away which is so
[__] sad man that's so crazy she
passed away when she hit 100 right was
it 100 that i don't think she didn't hit
100 yet you know oh she's quite sad
dummy
99 years old and then she passed away
before she hit 100.
that's [__] up yep but you know what
at least she made it to 99. that's a big
accomplishment yeah nobody cares about
the [__] what kids all right
let's be honest nobody cares about if
she could make it or couldn't make it
she had a great life she was a good 99
though like think about being 99 years
old even the fact that she could film
that commercial and i could stand and
[__] i'll be honest if i'm living until
99 just kill me i can't well actually it
depends because if you're like betty
white 99 though where do you think it
starts falling off is my question if i
can't choose steak that's when i die
because i can't do it so i'd say like 80
80.
my grandpa lived till he was 97. you
don't think betty white be consuming
steak like later in her year so i guess
she wasn't recording there wasn't any
like recordings of her in her later
years there's just her being there's
like photos of people like helping her
out of her car and stuff but she could
walk and stuff like that but she needed
assistance from somebody else just in
case she fell or something but there
hasn't been like an actual recording of
her in the last like three or four years
that's true i mean she's 99 years old
yeah the only people that i know that
are like 99 and are still very
functional like japanese people that's
very true like japanese live the longest
dude joe's gonna live to a thousand
years yeah well he's getting younger now
he's benjamin button he for real when
that fool had covered he'd even know he
had like no symptoms wow he was
perfectly fine i don't think you think
he has sniffles
those japs man they're strong
her bro
i just shortened it
you know what i mean yeah that's what
they were doing too
i think [__] is a i'm bringing it back
you can't bring it in i think it's
racially derogatory there's like
newspapers saying that it's like the n
word for japanese people yeah you're
right you're right you're right
what if a dark asian man says it dark
asian i don't think you could say it at
all i'm head to toe wearing uniqlo
there's a homie uh
i don't get credit i don't get points
for this is that all uniqlo right now
just just the pants on the shirt so not
really the feet but like you know mid
shin up
uniqlo down pretty good your strong's 20
yo you know what i mean this is a good
shirt your socks are endangered though
huh yeah shout out to somebody from
endangered la
is that a good brand it's uh she sells
shoes in uh in pasadena oh my boy darren
shout out is it a consignment store
i don't know what that i don't know what
you
rude you know it's like rip la you have
you been to roof lake yeah nah so riff
you [__] use your spider i'm gonna
riff l.a what the [__] is rough l.a i'd
rather go into la though
do you know
you don't like storage like online
stores like goat uh stockx so basically
people
uh they buy their shoes whatever for
whatever price that they have it and
they sell it for a higher price and
they'll do it on goat uh stockx uh
you've never heard of this before i've
never heard of this in my life really
yeah uncultured bridge
cultured groot you've never heard of
like so you if you see those short
stores with all those shoes like wrapped
up in plastic those are consignment
stores so everybody brings their shoes
there to sell it to somebody else okay
that's not really a sneaker head though
i'm really not he's just like just a
pair of shoes
every day dude
we never let that down
in 2022 we're still bringing it up
i gotta let chris know you came into
that ring like a fat [__]
you look like you had six kids and a
[__] cigarette addiction you know i
think i think chris sosa doesn't like me
ever i don't think he he hasn't talked
to us since that fight you know why i
think yeah yeah tommy looks at you he
gets mad
yeah i don't know when's the last time
you talk to him have you talked to him
the other day
i message him all the time no text back
yeah you do hey friend no you don't you
don't text me i text them all the time
what did you text him last night what'd
you say i was hey chris are you still
mad at me no no response no response no
response chris did you call him poppy
though
i said thomas at the end
chris is doing i mean he has a studio
now out in houston i think he's opening
up a recording studio there um we're
planning to do
a quick little stand-up show in march
depending on the the the omarion variant
you know we should get my good friend
who's also a comedian named patrick
riley you should also do that
that's coming for sure dude and guess
who's opening for us dude so this guy
[Applause]
and i want you to start it off with two
guys walking to a bar here we go i don't
think i have anything important to say
start it i don't give a [__] you're on
the podcast two guys walk into a bar
that's how you're gonna start no
stand-up starts with two guys walking
into a bar two guys walk into a bar why
am i so sweaty right now
it's happening
2022 you're a new men you're going to
own up to this you're going to do your
first stand-up set here we go is there a
class i could take yes there is okay
what are the comments hard knocks you
get no classes
go so uh you ever noticed when uh two
two guys walk into a bar um
i want to say jab's really bad
because that's the only thing i could
think of
oh that's i could bring that back you
could bring it but now i gotta figure
out a way where i make the two guys walk
into the bar japanese like what's easy
two guys walk into a bar they're
japanese boom bang there we go
now and then nick yells
[Laughter]
because that is not okay and i've
learned that this is a racial slur so
i'm not going to be using this term
anymore okay
and have you guys heard of the
aristocrat joke yes what the [__] is
that from i don't know it's
the craziest thing i've ever heard i
only heard of the aristocrat joke
yesterday
hey yo like what's an aristocrat the
first time i heard it was
what's in the wrist yeah what's the
definition of aristocrat it's a movie
about cats
and they're politicians
so i mean just speaking of that joke
r.i.p bob sage
so i i saw this it was his movie right
wasn't it was it the cats well i no not
that
the aristocrat joke like i remember that
was i don't remember i remember if there
was a documentary where they follow a
bunch of different comedians and they
tell their version of the aristocrats
joke right which is all the whole point
of the bit is they do all this crazy
wild [__] and at the very end they go
where are the aristocrats like that's
the point i just don't understand it
like what what does that mean i think it
has to go back to with what aristocrat
is i think it's not i think it's funny
because it doesn't make sense like i
think that's the whole point of it you
just lead somebody down this like crazy
filthy thing because it gets crazier and
crazier and crazier pissing and [__]
on each other yeah you guys [__]
everybody in that so if you guys haven't
seen it just look up the aristocrat joke
and you'll see a bunch of comedians do
it like almost in an anthology so for
example r.i.p bob saget will talk about
that but bob saget uh he did like a
seven minute version of it where bob
sage is just like okay there's a mother
and a father and they all want to have a
[__] orgy with their kids he rips off
his wife's clothes and he rips off her
pubes and the butt is going down her leg
and then he starts
[__] her face with his fat [__] yeah
i said his daughter comes in he slaps
her in the face and she's like i want to
suck your dick so he starts face [__]
his daughter and then his son comes
around and then his son he starts
[__] his son in the ass and he's in
pain so he starts throwing up into the
daughter's mouth and it just goes on and
on and it's the most disgusting [__] you
ever hear of it and he just goes
the aristocrats yeah we're the
aristocrats and that's the joke that's
the bit the bit is that it does it's
it's like what the [__] was that what
did you just do to me for so long yeah
it's the craziest [__] i've ever seen
yeah yeah i don't i don't i don't
[__] get it at all but the first time
i saw it was gilbert the dude with the
voice gilbert goddard yeah we were
talking about that today yeah
yo check this out i'm about to blow your
[__] penis off right now very nice
i'm excited
please here if i get a zipper go down
what the hell oh [__] that's not gilbert
godfrey's real voice
what do you mean so you know the iago
voice
the huh you know hi i'm gilbert godfrey
yeah yeah that's not his real voice
you don't talk like this he doesn't talk
about
like this like like this
like this like a [__] weddle
no he just has a normal speaking voice
but i i saw him on he was on joe rogan's
podcast
so he just does that all the time so
it's a bit he's been doing this
character for 40 [__] years
that's not gilbert godfrey's voice how
have you have you seen a clip of him yes
there's a so if he was one of the like
original snl cast members so if you look
at him in his original sketches it's
just his regular voice there's also this
clip that everybody can look up online
look up just google uh howard stern
gilbert gottfried and he's being
interviewed and there's a voice message
that gilbert godfrey's leaving somebody
and they play it and it's the most
regular [__] you'll ever hear in your
life no way disappointing isn't it 40
years he kept it up
in interviews he was literally on the
joe rogan podcast and he was doing the
voice the whole time yeah joe when i was
doing stand-up comedy back in my day you
know and i'm like whoa dude that's
insane what a level of [__]
commitment and he does it so well it
just sounds like natural yeah it doesn't
sound like he's putting on a character
but
that's not his voice so when he talks
normally
are his eyes still squinted too no he
just actually just pulls it back like
this
yeah yeah yeah isn't he part asian no
he's like he's not rob schneider rob
schneider's like filipino isn't he yeah
i think he's filipino i don't know i
don't know what the [__] that fool is
he's jewish he's yeah i think god i
think if he has a freed at the end
you're you're jewish or field
seinfeld steen
huh yeah steener stein steinstein
yeah yep i think he's i think he's
jewish
he has a documentary on amazon
about him and you could hear his regular
speaking voice he's been doing this
character for 40 years how do you feel
about this does that bother you
it kind of [__] me up a little bit
yeah it's kind of it's it's uh i don't
say disappointing but it is kind of like
what the [__]
i want to know why like why why did you
do this yeah why
because i'm pretty sure all of his jokes
would have been funny with it without
the voice they're without the voice and
the voices i like to a lot of people
very [__] annoying too so it's not
like it's uh like not to me but like
i've met a lot of people who've been
like [__] i don't want to like that
guy's talking
you know it's not like a he was the uh
aflac duck yeah aflac oh he's the alpha
he's the aflac duck guy
didn't he do a poo from simpsons too no
no i know it's yeah yeah idiot
hank azaria is the guy
yeah but they're they're not even
who's not even on uh simpsons anymore
yeah yeah that guy like he he felt bad
that he was taking like
an indian person could have had that
role and he like he quit indian people
really i mean i could imagine so yeah i
bet there was a certain group i bet you
there's a lot of white people that are
upset about it too
that's what's [__] annoying that's
the most annoying part is
what's come to america well we can't
have a [__] white guy imitated indian
guy for [__] 50 years on television
yeah yeah i don't know i don't i i don't
know why i guess as an asian i didn't
really find it offensive maybe because
it was so good yeah it was pretty good
yeah would you be mad if there was a
korean character on simpsons and he was
played by a white guy exactly
very stereotypical because he came
through and he was like oh hero
you know i'm a number one it's a quarter
if a white guy did that yeah i wouldn't
care as long as it's accurate isn't that
kind of more impressive anyway when like
somebody that's not your race that could
do an accent that well hey it's kind of
like
that's a good action that's pretty good
that's good acting i can't be mad at it
russell peters did such a good [__]
like cantonese chinese accent so good oh
yeah nobody could say [__] because he
understood like the cultural nuance
right yeah so when he was making all
these jokes it wasn't at the expense of
chinese people it was a joke it was an
inside joke and that's what he did
really well this podcast is brought to
you by babble my friends my lovely
genius brain farts at the top of my list
is learning a new language and it's
gonna be with babble my friends i ain't
no chauncey ass [__] i only do
my stuff with babel the learning
language app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions my friends i am
trying to learn spanish the best that i
can and i do it with my babble baby
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons for real world use and let me
tell you something i love babble because
it teaches you the language in the way
that i want to learn you know if you
guys took spanish in high school or any
other foreign language they kind of
teach you in a way that a lot of people
don't use or speak the language and
that's the most annoying part because
i'll be you know outside in the real
world thinking that you know this is how
people speak and they don't and it gets
all confusing and i get embarrassed did
i get with you shy
plus babble speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and action my friends not
like the way i just said my english
words right now but you get the gist of
it so right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use promo code
gb that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com code gb babble language
for life nope like for me too like let's
say the the guy who does a korean accent
is a white guy but it's so accurate i'd
be busting i'd be laughing dude andrew
santino when he does when he like when
he's [__] around bobby lee like it's
pretty accent that's just funny as [__]
that's pretty funny have you seen andrew
santino uh live on his stand-up i have
did you like it i did i haven't seen him
live before but i saw his
i saw some of his clips i like him as a
podcaster better than as a stand-up
comic though what the the are you
talking about the amazon special that he
has yeah yeah yeah yeah i've seen it i
don't remember it actually but i need to
re-watch it [__] disrespectful guys i
don't remember if i liked it it was a
long time ago i seen it but i don't
remember if i really liked it or not but
i feel like nowadays watching stand up
on
like at home just kind of doesn't i
think across the board doesn't really
hit that wall
it has to be so there's there's
definitely it's better live yeah stand
up is always a better life but there are
but that's when you know that like
because chappelle's special still even
if i'm watching my home or a dude
elephant in the room patrice o'neil i've
seen it so many times it doesn't matter
i'm [__] dying
too because the whole time i know
certain people so for example like a lot
of people [__] on kevin hart but i've
seen kevin hart live three times
live he was hella funny yeah i saw that
same set on tv and i didn't laugh yeah
so i don't know what the [__] it is but
when i when i watched um i forgot which
set it was but
i wasn't tears laughing live it was so
[__] hilarious and then for some
reason his comedy doesn't translate very
well when it's recorded it's
completely different like i don't
understand why though there's like an
energy thing that happens like when
you're live and you just i think you
just hop on the ride a little quicker
with when you're there in person but
also too
i've seen other specials like louis ck
like oh my god like i don't know if he
where he's in the round he's like in the
round he's running
the first time i saw it on tv i didn't
think it was that funny but that the
more i watch it the funnier i think it
is that one so sometimes that happens to
me too where like i watch one the first
time i'm like and then i watch it again
and again and each time it gets better
and better i don't know why that that's
happened to me too but chappelle's just
one of those guys that just has magic
it's funny no matter what it's no matter
what he's so prolific that's why too
like he commands the because it's
chappelle
he commands the room a little bit even
when you're in your living room like
everyone is glued to whatever he's
saying yeah because you know he's gonna
have some
like the way he wraps up his points are
just it's so like different he's
interesting no matter what yeah even if
he's not funny you're still like damn
this guy's making great points he's very
wise yeah the way he talks is very like
calm and soothing it's he's just got all
the elements blended together perfectly
you know just to wrap it back to like
bob saget i've been watching you know
all the all the the stand-up comics that
i follow i had no idea how much and i
don't it doesn't feel like people are
talking about bob saget just because he
passed away they're saying nice things
yeah like it sounds like he was super
loved like everybody has an amazing
story about him mm-hmm freaking uh nick
was it nikki glacier
like that like the ice thing glacier
yeah glacier
she said multiple nice things about him
had multiple posts about him miss pat
[__] said amazing things about him
and the crazy thing about that is too
it's like he seems super low-key it
doesn't seem like a lot of people really
know bob saget very well aside from the
full house thing but comics know him as
the comic guy yeah he's a canadian's
comedian like everyone seemed like they
really liked him like i i don't don't
remember one of his bits but i remember
a long time ago he had like a comedy
central half hour special and i was
watching i remember it was so [__]
funny but once again don't remember
anything from it so i guess it's time to
revisit that [__] huh he was super he's
dead you [__] dick yeah dude pay
tribute yo the next time i see bob oh
that's right
oh damn i remember anytime he plays
himself on a tv show he always like
plays like a super [__]
like i remember he was like entourage or
some [__] and he played like a crazy
like
sex addict [__] and would you
imagine like oh that's [__] full
house guy that's a dad yeah that's the
father danny tanner i didn't know i
didn't know he was because i only seen
him on full house and then the first
time i saw his special like his stance
crazy it's just dirty like my dick balls
suck from the back ass like this
i was like
he's vietnamese
i hate that dick suck on the ass man
don't whatever it doesn't just be boxing
his mom sagging man
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
that you were talking about it's the one
that everybody was talking about because
he hadn't done a stand-up special in so
long
everybody knew him as danny tanner the
wholesome [__] dad bro he was on
america's home videos
or that yeah exactly america's [__]
home funny whatever was that for him to
to be this character in this image when
that's not who he is yeah
he was telling the story i think he was
on joe rogan's uh podcast and he was
talking about um the opportunity that
came up with full house and it just i
think everybody thought that what the
[__] how is he gonna do this this isn't
bob saget yeah and then but it became
literally the biggest like family
television show ever next to like full
house fresh prince uh uh family matters
and it's like that iconic area yeah they
were all so good too i remember
different reasons i remember hearing him
tell stories about how when he so he got
big obviously off a full house and then
people started coming to his shows but
he was like half the room would stay and
like half the room would just what the
[__] because they were like oh let's go
see it's like family people like oh he's
gonna do a nice show and then he comes
out vietnamese
and they're
[Laughter]
come taste funny
man
wake up in the morning feeling like a
pee duty man
that had to be so funny though and that
was there was no internet back then so
it was like people like people would
learn one show at a time it wasn't like
a big show would happen and the word
would get on twitter like people had to
just learn
one show at a time so it took years for
the word to completely get out that he
comes out just talks about wild ass [__]
like this is who bob saget is and then
yeah exactly and you had all these like
fine dining type people in there
we're just like holy [__] this one's
talking about [__] hookers in the ass
and all kinds of crazy [__] did you do
that though what it's like somebody came
up it's like i want to put you on the
sitcom and you have to play this
wholesome father figure
yeah i would do it dude i think you
could i think you i think you kind of
resemble the next bob sagan
if you do some glasses oh my god you're
amazing he's a [__] trailer trash
white guy now
bam shaggy
that's pretty [__] good bro yeah hey
that's your demo right there
[__]
don't don't [__] on my your demo okay oh
my bad it's true babs i think you could
be that guy i could be bob said that
sweater that bob saggett looking
sweaters i feel like that's what you
would wear this one ben affleck smoking
the cigarette
exactly
dude the best part
speaking of
the [__] that green room thing where
it was bob sagan and patrice o'neill
just
ripping into bob saget how good was that
the best that shows the [__] too it's
called green room i think with i think
it's called green room i don't remember
i think it is why did that show not
continue it's literally the best show
ever because comics unleashed took it
over that's why the show way better show
comics at least was the worst it was my
favorite it's basically they go before
the show and they go hey do you have a
bit that you want to perform yeah i'll
ask you a question heard you had a had a
funny story with coconut water
and then you tell your [__] [__] it
was so bad that the way they would set
it up they're like blah blah blah
they're chopping it up and they're like
yeah it's kind of like you know when
when it rains in l.a
[Laughter]
oh my god this is terrible oh that sucks
what was that was that
was that comics unleashed when that fan
got ripped into no that was uh that's
every show he's on tough crowd with
colin quinn oh that show was a [__] that
was like podcasts before podcasting
that fan dude that's what it is yeah he
did he did jackie she ripped him off he
ripped off his own oh i like this [__]
daphne performs at like open mic
sometimes around here like there's one
in pasadena he's at a lot and like i've
seen him at the moment
yeah it's kind of like it's kind of it's
kind of i haven't seen him but i just
say how you feel bro it's kind of like
i was just kind of like i haven't seen
it but it's just like it's just kind of
weird vibes yeah and i i don't think you
could do that acting does he still do
the same act i haven't seen him but i'm
just saying the way like like so
there'll be a flyer and it'll be like
all these girls and then that fan oh
yeah
and then and then yeah it's just kind of
weird i don't know i don't know for sure
but i've heard some people interact with
them too really what are those actually
not girls do what they say they're just
like yeah this seems kind of weird and i
i mean i'm talking about [__] i guess
that's all i say we need to get him on
this podcast dude he's around he's local
he's around and then bobby lee's going
to kill me
like that i haven't had bobby on the
podcast
bobby lee on it huh bobby lee hates
stefan oh dude they're like mortal
enemies oh really yeah dude on his
podcast openly on tiger belly in the
beginning episodes he would just [__] on
that fan all the time why i don't know i
think it's like his arch nemesis okay i
think he just i don't know what it is
but there's something about them too but
there's a lot of like asian comics that
feel a certain way about that fan and i
think maybe it's because he does too
much of his his mom vietnamese bit
because that's all he does though yeah
literally i kind of want to see his act
now i don't i don't i it's been so long
like he's got he he's got to have some
new materials
yeah what are the different scenarios
with his mom
more scenarios you know to that argument
too then so does joe coy every every set
that joe coy does is about his filipino
mom and nobody's giving him [__] yeah
but then again joko is actually really
funny joko is funny but the thing is
jokoy doesn't just depend on the voice
too to be
funny it's just there's different
situations that involve his mom exactly
you know
because maybe he's like relying too much
on the accent and we kind of just get
sick of it well that's like the kind of
the punch line you know it's just the
fun that he just does that the accent
yeah yeah
yeah yeah because i love joe coy joko's
[__] joker's the [__] like he's like
one of those people whatever he does his
mom it's like the it's the bit that's
funny it's not that his mom is the
accent's funny itself right it's just
that's how his mom and a lot of times he
doesn't even like i mean i know i'm sure
he does a voice but like a lot of times
that i remember it's not even like him
doing it it's just like the situation or
whatever the [__] happened is funny like
it's not just like the last two it's
like do you care if like comics do like
asian accents like no i think that's a
part of our [__] if we grew up with that
that's how the people we were around
sound like if that's how my friends
sound like then yeah but is the joke
funny yeah you know is it funny the
funny part should never be the accent
it's just an an accent to what it is
like this is how my mom speaks like if i
imitate my mom right i'm not gonna
imitate her with an english
accent she doesn't have one yeah it's
[__] north korean [__]
north korea
that would actually be funnier if in
real life you were like oh this is
someone my mom says and you speak like a
regular english you mom is so
disrespectful dude because i went back
to sacramento uh uh before christmas
right i forget how many times this woman
tells me to kill myself like that's
actually
what does that sound like in korean she
said if you say like a very like casual
way it would just be like tj tj means
like to go [__] off and die
that's a casual way
[__] off and even the way she talks
about like i didn't realize growing up
that these specific things were not
normal so for example like she would say
like she forgot to water the plants and
she go
that means like this [__] plant just
[__] off and died so it's not a common
thing to say but she didn't teach me the
[__] so i come out to la i'm in k-town
and i'm talking like a [__] gangster
because that's how my mom talks and so
i'm getting i'm embarrassed now yeah so
that's gangster time so you don't
[__] say a plant just [__] off and
dies yeah that's pretty important that's
pretty aggressive
he just saw which it's there's no [__]
off in it but it's that's how aggressive
it sounds right and you can ask any kind
of person they don't ever exactly they
don't say a plant just you know tease
yourself they'll be like chugosa
what does that mean
he's like it died
like yourself
i like that that's how you just sort of
yeah
and like here's a here's a [__]
when you go back home to like we started
talking about my aunts right so my dad
has two older sisters
it's so hilarious when i look back at
the stuff that they would do like to me
at the time when i was looking at it's
not a big deal but when you compare your
life to other people's family lives this
stuff doesn't [__] happen so one time
my aunt for whatever reason it was i
don't remember what happened but
my
my oldest aunt from korea flew to the
united states after her husband passed
away to ask my father for forgiveness
for something that she did in the past
so she's feeling a lot of regret it's
very noble and by the way korean people
if you don't know are very dramatic
so they should be literally on the floor
sobbing wow like begging for forgiveness
and my dad's just staring at her so i
don't know what happened between them
and i remember this as a kid
and then the next day like everything's
super fine but
she also has a younger sister my dad's
older sister than the middle child
the next day i see them and i see my
heart come in her hair's all frayed my
other aunt has a scratch on her face and
then one of them has like a black eye
i'm like what happened they're like we
got in a fight in the car on the way
here whoa
in the car yeah and then i see the side
of her hair there's a loogie in her head
so oh my gosh
spit in her [__] hair holy [__] at
that still in there they're driving
she's driving to the house so she's
attacking her as she's [__]
[__]
you know and it's weird as a kid i heard
this story and i'm just like i and i
just moved on but as an adult i'm like
that's not normal yeah you shouldn't be
doing stuff like that don't be fighting
the car like that
nah dude not like that this podcast is
brought to you by adam and eve my
friends what should be your new year's
resolution it should be getting better
boom boom
better sex a little shoploik i think
i think that's a word for sex my friends
listen if you haven't been to
adamandeve.com they got just about
earthing for you to get that little [__]
blah blah on baby we got lingerie we got
vibrators sexy toys women sex toys men's
sex toys abundance lubes and sexual
wellness listen i know this might seem a
little weird like why is why is genius
brain sponsoring this because guess what
we don't stray away from sexual
exploration my friends let me tell you
something adam and eve has your back and
guess what genius brain has your back as
well adam and eve if it's offering 50
off just about any item plus free
shipping on your entire order don't say
i never did nothing for you so when
you're having that grain chapery
think of me that's what i want you to
think i want you to really think of me
so just go to adamandeve.com is select
any one item it could be an adventurous
new toy or anything you desire just
enter offer code genius at checkout and
you'll get 50 off almost any item go
check out adamandeve.com today select
one item and get fifty percent off
including free shipping when you enter
offer code genius that's g-e-n-i-u-s
genius
adam and eve dot com
not like a [__] have you ever seen
like one of your family members try to
fight another family member like i've
heard stories i've heard stories i've
had stories like that too on my dad's
side especially like dudes would fight
all the time but i've never seen it with
my own eyes
you never i've let me tell you something
man like my family is ver
i remember my uncle
so now he's kind of like he had he had a
stroke like a pretty severe stroke so
he's not the same as he used to be he's
a really funny goofy dude but this guy
used to have a temper problem
my oldest cousin i remember i wasn't
there but
i think my cousin ran away at this point
because he threw a [__] meat cleaver
at him damn [__] so if you go to that
old duplex with you
i remember that this little slice
holy [__] chucked it at him but he
missed him where the [__] do you get a
meat cleaver from asian people we just
that's what we have you just got them we
just got meat cleavers one time i was a
kid my mom threatened me with the
[__] meat cleaver because i was
[__] around i forgot what i was doing
very very over the top but she [__]
put a cleaver in my [__] face and was
like yo in your face you're about to get
it dude for real
do you remember what you did i forgot i
didn't see your bottom line did she show
your bottom teeth when people were
putting her
yeah she was she was ready to show up
yeah
it always creeps me out when he posts a
family picture and his sister is just
him with long hair i know yeah yeah you
guys look like the craziest thing ever
there's no difference there isn't you
have the same face yeah it's crazy if
you guys face swap same picture honestly
i've done that app before and i look
like my sister yeah people have come up
to me
like random people i've never met my
life and i go hey you got a sister
and i go yeah
and then they say
is her name ashley that's my sister's
name and i go yeah she goes yeah i knew
you you were ashley's sister sammy
brothers you guys you're the same face
and it's people that she went to high
school with that still come up to me to
this day randomly like oh you have a
sister name actually huh and i go yep
i believe i'm
we have so many different pictures of us
we're all like oh god this is the same
exact face there's nothing we could do
about it do you guys look i saw your mom
so you guys look more like your dad
i guess i think you guys look more like
your dad more combo of like my dad my
middle sister looks more like my mom
yeah straight up like when they were
little when they were like
well there was a picture of my mom when
she was like 20 something she looks
exactly like my sister they're like
standing the same and [__] in this
picture it's nuts it's crazy but you
know i look just like is it always
[__] weird for somebody who dates
your sister and then they see you
they're just like and i'm always licking
my lips
like what the hell you want this one
[Music]
if you're walking down the street and
then somebody just comes up to you and
they're like you know what you're brave
and they go why the sex change
[Laughter]
the sex change you are brave yeah bro
you know what i
we should i should get my sister on here
one day and we just we just shoot the
[__] with her she got some crazy stories
about me too i would love to hear it
dude we should just have like you start
on the podcast and then like get up at
one just don't say anything
and then i see how many people actually
notice that that happens if there's
anybody that likes to set me on fire
more than you guys it's my sisters yeah
they love to [__] just roast me a new
one bro did you get bullied by your
sister dude i got [__] i'm so i'm
mentally destroyed like every time i see
them i get like weird flashbacks worst
thing one of your sisters did to you hey
you know what okay okay this is not the
worst thing but this is the type of [__]
i should deal with where my sister my
older sister is seven years older than
me
and i remember one time i came back home
from high school it was senior year and
i walked in the house just smelling like
pot a wreath-like pot and i i was with
my boys and they were smoking in the car
and i was with them and i happened to
partake as well but i come home and my
mom goes you smell like pot she's
screaming at me she's about to like kick
my [__] ass and i'm like no i didn't
i wasn't smoking i swear they were just
smoking so i make up this whole [__]
lie and i'm faded as [__] i'm so
like i'm in bed my heart's beating on my
chest my mama's yelling all night don't
even notice your mom is a green eyed
monster
dude this [__] tentacled monsters
yelling at me i was tripping out so
[__] hard so the next morning
my sister comes up to me my oldest
sister she goes bro like you were
smoking huh and i go no i wasn't i kept
holding this lie i didn't i wasn't
smoking at all she goes come on like
just i won't say nothing but i promise
what a [__]
she kept coercing me and i go yeah i was
smoking like all right just don't tell
mom all right she goes okay
later that night oh my mom goes hey uh
let me talk to you for a second in the
kitchen like walk in that's the hood
saying from a [__] you up dude yeah if
somebody from the hood says let me talk
to you for a second you about to get
[__] up getting knocked down yeah
about to get jumped so we're in the
kitchen
and my mom goes so uh
your sister told me that you were
smoking oh my god
damn bro
i couldn't say anything i don't know
what i don't know maybe she thought in
her mind that she needed to tell my mom
that i was like smoking pot or whatever
but that's so whack my whole my whole my
mom was super mad at me my sister was
like kind of annoying me too and my dad
was like yeah what are you going to do
high as [__] my dad was smoking pot our
whole [__] job did you how did you
make amends with your sister after being
a [__] narc yeah i don't that's why i
don't tell them nothing bro i don't tell
them [__] to this day yeah that's a
relationship killer you literally told
her [__] eyeball to eyeball you you
guys had the same face
my oldest sister
the one i looked just like and i was
like listen
i can trust you this is what's gonna
happen don't tell mama she goes got it
and then she walked away hey mom let me
tell you what this pot
your pot head's up dude yeah just snitch
on me hard but they would do that like
they would always if i heard it from my
mom i would hear it from my two sisters
about her from my sister right here from
my mom and then my other sister i was
constantly just getting [__] [__] on
growing up what was your payback did you
ever [__] get them back
you know i just [__] do my own thing
you never got that bad well like it's
part of it is just like what are you
gonna do are you an only child you have
siblings only child you have any cousins
i have cousins yeah cousins are gonna
[__] you over like that not like that
well i'm older the ones that are older
than me are mexico so i didn't spend
like that much time with them i would
see them periodically but the younger
cousin who i was talking about earlier
we used to fight all the [__] time
but i was older uh you'd [__] he
would just he would just like like he
was so [__] annoying dude like
so he doesn't start crying i'm sorry i
mean he knows he knows okay and then in
the beginning like he used to come over
and like he would like i'm just just any
way someone could be annoying he would
do it and he would just be a dick and i
would tell him like yo stop i'ma [__]
you up he wouldn't stop and i'd end up
[__] him up right i always gave him a
lot of warning signs anyways my family
used to get mad at me my family used to
get mad at me because they're like
you're older than him you should [__]
not hit him
got to the point where literally like i
they were coming and he was pissing me
off i went in the kitchen my whole
family i was like eight maybe i don't
even know how old i was but i announced
the family i was like if you guys don't
get me away from this kid i'm gonna [__]
his ass up like i've told you guys so
many times i was like i don't care
anymore i was like eight year old keep
people away from me or i'ma beat the
[__] out of him and it's gonna be your
fault and i just laugh blood is on yours
and then they were like and then after
that like i would still
sometimes we get into fights but i
wouldn't get in trouble anymore because
it was like yeah like i bro i went
inside
that he was actually mentally [__]
and then you were beating up a child who
had issues
ah dude but he was like dude he would
like shut up he would always try like i
would just be playing he would just come
and bite me on my back or some dumb [__]
like that
yeah it was just like some d like he
would always like he was just a [__]
[__] i got in a fight with him on
christmas one time
dude i got to fight with him
and this is like i was a little older i
was like probably
like 15 at the time
and the whole night he'd been like
following me around like y'all get the
[__] away from me like just doing
annoying [__] like like it mimicked like
just any way he could be annoying
and uh we're finally leaving right and
he like me my dad and my mom and we're
leaving and we're like all right and i
was kind of proud of myself i was like i
made it through the day i didn't hit him
you know i practiced self-restraint it's
christmas this is a family time this is
family time
we're walking out and he runs in front
of me and he like make she just made
some stupid ass like
i don't know it was just it was it was
just the last thing like i couldn't take
it anymore it was like
and i [__]
open hand slap [__] ripple open hair
slap
palmed his whole head and he like flew
off like the frame and then i just
smiled and i kept walking and then he
ran in front of me again and punched me
in the face
boom
and i like saw i just i remember just
reaching out and grabbing him and just
seeing red like i wasn't even looking i
was like
and i felt my mom about to grab me to
pull me off and i heard my dad go nah he
deserves he like he's like nah
so my dad grabbed my mom and was like
now let it happen and i just slapped the
[__] out of him like six like blah blah
blah blah blah david's little style and
then he ran in the house crying and then
me and my parents my dad was like yo we
gotta go cause there's an issue here we
just gotta fight and then we just
your dad is the most irresponsible
parent i've ever heard in my life hey we
gotta get the [__] out of here let's go
let's go
that was such a g bro anytime there
would be something about fights or
anything fighting related
he would be he would get his dick hard
you know deal with it and like her so
responsible she goes
your father goes not today
it must be done
that was like leonidas bro my dad was
wild bro like
i have vivid memories in in elementary
school of my so like i would go to
because i went to south pacino as a nice
neighborhood i'd go learn like nice
neighborhood type education [__] and
then i'd go home and my dad would teach
me like how to [__] like get away
with murder base or like how to [__]
somebody up and like evade the law so
like i remember if you like lessons
fights like he would he would tell me uh
like he used to tell me in elementary
school he's like yo don't get in a fight
at school you're gonna get in trouble
like don't you don't want to get like
suspended that happened to me a lot he's
like if you have a problem with somebody
at school just invite them over like you
can you guys can have a one-on-one i'll
make sure no one's right he's like my
dad was like i'll referee it just invite
you like if you have a problem with
someone just invite him or catch him
after school catch him alone catch his
hands you're dead irish or something
yeah yeah oh my god and then he was
irish he would be like he's the departed
he's based
[__] off
i used to tell kids like when i had
problems i'd be like yo you want to come
over and they were like what the [__]
you mean
don't understand the threat like you
want to hang out what's up you [__]
loser oh you trying to come to my house
yeah bro it was my dad was wild but
honestly that's probably one of the most
responsible ways to handle some [__]
honestly it kind of we need a little bit
of that just tell your kid if he if some
kid is bullying your child and you're
like all right come to the house and you
guys get one-on-ones and there's going
to be adult supervision making sure that
no one gets you know yeah hurt too bad
yeah that's pretty good a lot of 78
counts come on not a cigarette smoke in
the air for sure yeah a lot of sugar
it's smaller that's standard that's
that's just so funny too because i know
with parents they tend to have like
selective memory like i remember when i
used to get in trouble a lot right so
because i just
by the way this is not like tough guy
stories just when you grow up in a poor
neighborhood everybody fights if you're
a geek nerd whatever everybody had to
fight it just is what it is so
growing up i used to get in a lot of
trouble because i'm getting a lot of
fist fights if i get suspended whatever
and then i remember one time my dad
looked at me he goes i don't know where
you think that you could just solve all
your problems with fighting and i'm
looking at him i was like are you
[__] dumb you
like you told me i should do this he
goes i never said this bro this is a
defining moment of my life i remember
this so back in the day uh if you used
to go to these flea markets you remember
there used to be this stick with like
glitter inside of it and when you would
flip it around
so my little [__] sorry ass
uh back in the day we used to call
myself gay right we wouldn't use that
derogatory term now but that's what
people would have what would it be what
would it be now it would be just be a
man with good life choices
this podcast is brought to you by
ship station my friends oh have we
talked about ship station on this
podcast before because i love ship
station if ship station was a person i
would consensually kiss them on the
mouth non-stop until my lips fall off
shipping delay supply shortages holiday
demands last year was a freaking mess
now you're ringing in the new year with
impatient customers returns and
expensive shipping rates well it's time
to switch to a shipping solution that
can handle it all painlessly and that
ship station my friends import orders
from any sales channel ship using any
carrier with deeply discounted rates
automate just about any shipping task if
you have an online business if you're
selling anything through any whatever
avenue you need to use ship station
trust me customer service and shipping
stuff is literally one of the hardest
things to ever deal with trust me i know
i have a clothing clothing company and
uh yeah it's probably one of the more
difficult parts of doing it but shift
station makes everything so easy save
time by funneling all your orders into
one simple interface and no matter what
you're selling manage every order amazon
ebay etsy or even your own website save
money save your sanity no wonder 98 of
companies that use substation for a for
a year keep using it for as long as
they're in business it's that freaking
good [__] more and less time with ship
station use my offer code geniusbrain to
get a 60 day free trial that's two
months free of no hassle stress free
shipping just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in geniusbrain ship
station make ship
but uh i had one and then there was
these two kids in the neighborhood that
jacked my glitter stick right and then i
was just like
that's life
yes i don't have a blue stick anymore
and you know we're poor as [__] so when
you have stuff it's very important that
you keep it you have to keep it for as
long as possible so they took the stick
from me
and i went home my dad's like where's
the [__] toy that i got you today he
goes oh these kids stole it from me and
he goes
okay well no dinner and you're not
coming to this house till you get it
back oh and he closes the door on me
whoa that's [__] tight so i had to go
back i had to get a [__] fist fight
with these kids and i didn't get that
[__] back
i [__] got into a fist fight with two
of these kids it was an older brother
and a younger brother and it was this
little whatever kitty brawl you know and
i got my [__] back and i ran home my dad
and i showed him the stick it was almost
like a key like like
i beat the level it's like please let me
hit
dinner's ready and he let me inside the
house oh wow and i wasn't allowed to
come back in until i brought this back
so when i was when i first came here i
couldn't speak english so i was like two
or three years old when i came here so
my first language was korean so i used
to get bullied a lot yeah so my dad
always said you can't do anything if
they if they put their hands on you then
do whatever the [__] you want and so
that's how i would solve my problems so
it would like you would be like come
over from my house
put your hands on me and see what
happens yeah it would be the same line i
would always say because that's the only
way i wouldn't get my ass be at home is
if they were the first ones to hit me
mm-hmm because then i wouldn't get in
trouble it would be self-defense so it
would always just i would just say go
ahead do whatever you want get the first
swing and then after that we would just
see what happens damn my parents suck
bro they wouldn't tell you anything like
that no my dad would be like i got
conflicting messages my father would be
like you got to stand up for yourself
but you also shouldn't be fighting in
school
and my mom would be like just tell the
teacher but i wouldn't do neither of
those things and i would just get beat
up
damn so i [__] i have zero i have
nothing damn that sucks dude your
[__] sisters would nark on you when
you get your ass yeah this one had no
[Music]
a friends
i'm hearing your guys's life stories and
i'm like man i didn't give [__] my dad
used to tell me to hit first he was like
if there's a pro he was like first of
all if you feel it rising he's like
start swinging
yeah he's like as soon as you notice
problems he's like it's he's like
[__] start swinging he's like then
you get a group of your friends to say
they were there and they saw him hit you
first
that's a criminal dude
that was he would tell it he would tell
me he told my friends too like when they
were over and he was like this is what
you do is that y'all ain't [__] narcs
are you
he starts getting a hot branch like
branding their forearms oh my god dude
this
is
you are now part of the clan in the sign
of our people yeah dude there was no
check
so you didn't get you got in a fight
zone elementary school beat up damn
you see and it's
when i was in elementary school like i
wrote me up a lot actually honestly you
know what i am good at i'm gonna be in a
punching bag if there's anything i've
been trained my whole life to be is a
punching bag i can take punishment from
anybody and be pretty fine i think yeah
but that's you're going to be a school
shooter bro i know
you're going to blow up dude you're
going to blow up you're not even in
school anymore you're just going to go
to school and start shooting the [__]
place
that's true no i think my school shooter
days was in like middle school that's
when i was like really mad at the world
and [__] and then that's when i started
trying to fight people because i was
like [__] this yo i'm just getting beat
up all the time people call me [__] in
school damn i gotta start fighting
people yeah i just started doing
something and honestly that's when
people stop [__] with me
yeah you stood up for yourself yeah dude
it's just it's just nobody wants to
bully somebody who's problematic they're
always going to pick somebody who's not
going to fight back it's just an easy
target like if you f and this is all
very pending on how real the danger is
obviously if somebody has a knife to
your throat don't go [__] detroit you
you know survival guy maybe you should
just block from here urban survival
techniques or tactics or whatever i
don't know if you should just you know
do that [__] yeah yeah but it won't work
yeah but you know i got bullied by a
person named lorraine and you figure out
if that's a boy or a girl um
oh was it a girl oh actually no i think
it's a boy i thought initially i was a
girl first of all anybody who gets
bullied by the french
all right there was a black kid named
lorraine a guy a black kid named
lorraine i was thinking yeah and he's
still he used to terrorize me well hold
on a second
he's a terrific french
not not from like he wasn't from the
french side of wherever he was from
though like he was he was very like
well how'd you get bullied by a kid
named lorraine he was very problematic
this kid somebody called you
she's just been like your name is
lorraine i didn't even i i didn't even
know that was a girl's name i didn't
know that was something you could make
fun of the brain
i was i was so i was so not like
thinking that way at all yeah
everybody's my friend except lorraine
who would break my bruce lee lunch box
little bruce lee lunchbox lunch smash
that [__] yo
smash that [__] for what reason he just
came up to you and he was like blue
and apparently
he got kicked out of our elementary
school i don't know if he got kicked out
actually he got in a bunch of trouble
for throwing rocks over the freeway
overpass on cars
i wonder where he is now it's crazy that
there were those kids where you were
like damn they're these dudes are gonna
end up in jail a thousand percent dude i
just thought about this recently i
remember this kid in elementary school
this kid's name was ryan right and i
don't know what his family life was like
but once again like i don't question
things like there's an uncle throwing
cleavers at people and i'm thinking like
it's all
yeah but there's a kid named ryan i
remember he you know everybody would
bring like sack lunches or they would
have like the school food right and i
would just do the school food just
because i wanted american food because
my mom wouldn't you know make me this
american [__] so i would get like peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches which is
what all the poor kids would get because
they would have these sack lunches
because their parents couldn't afford
food but i'm like give me that [__] dude
yeah that [__] was funny that's what i
want yeah so
i would get that stuff but this kid
would always bring and eat uncooked hot
dogs uncooked weenies yeah so it would
just be like the ballpark [__]
the juice and everything and he would
rip it out and he would just start
eating like uncooked cocktails but it
was a square
and i'm like damn dude and when i look
back as an adult it's like dog what the
[__] was his uh child life like life in
his home yeah that they would let him
walk away and just just open up this
pack of hot dogs and i remember he had
to get held back
and here's the [__] up thing i
remember the teacher making him stand up
in front of class and tell everybody
that he's getting held back
damn you why
yeah
it's a isn't that crazy like i just
remember this [__] i remember how
embarrassed he looked and he was a
really cool kid too and listen
how fat i was that [__] i would
eat those hot dogs together
ryan's like raw hot dogs damn yeah
you're a feasting dude yeah
the time of my life
you know it's funny i did crave american
food has grown up too dude the i used to
[__] envy the kids who had the wonder
bread ham and cheese sandwich
i'm like let me get some of that
delicacy bro please
i just i used to look forward to like
school lunch some days
you know just because like my mom would
always make some food for me and
and like
we'd eat that all the time so i wanted
some new [__] like lunchables what a
treat lunchables yeah i wanted all that
stuff man and so like i remember
specifically just um
just i would try to trade anything that
i had so i would like just crave that
[__] wiper and say my mom would be
like why the [__] do you want to eat
this [__] it's not even good i'm like
you don't know [__]
that could be [__] fried rice and
[__]
[__] stupid
yes
you don't worry bring these hot dogs and
he would share with me and i'm like
you're really funny
where did you get this feast from
that would just be sitting there eating
raw hot dogs together wrong these
pickies up yeah
yo you got the hot dogs today baby
hot dogs and we just
you know damn but yeah the teacher
specifically i remember this kid his
head was down staring at his feet and he
was like she was like tell everybody
that you know you're going to be what's
happening to you next year he's like i
won't be able to join you guys next year
because i'm going to be held back what
grade were you guys in this was i if i
was at anna kercugater at the time this
was before i got expelled so the second
grade
they made them do that in a second
whatever [__] ass t-shirt
i'm looking
what the [__] was the purpose of that
yeah it just humiliated him yeah just
humiliated the [__] out of him and this
kid just like i i don't know how
terrible he felt
sitting there having to tell the whole
class that he's basically not as smart
as everybody and she was like stupid-ass
[__]
that's what you get for reading those
dumb [__] that's so [__] up though
like actually thinking about that like
imagine you're a teacher and that's what
you do to your [__] kid that there's
a lot of stuff that they used to do back
in the day that for sure i know they
wouldn't do now in the third grade i
remember this [__] right and i
don't remember
[__] [__] we used to do the times
table right
and so depending on how high up you can
go on the times table within a certain
time limit you will be awarded
um on ice cream fridays
um toppings so if you you know one times
one is one one times two still you go
through that whole thing well guess what
on your vanilla sundae now you could
have some sprinkles on it you do up to
two times two two times three two times
four and you can answer all that guess
what now you get to add bananas so the
smart kids would have a full-on sundae
sprinkles damn cherries bananas
[Applause]
i'm dumb
i would only have vanilla ice cream and
i just sat there with my sorry ass
vanilla ice cream just tearing up just
only eating vanilla ice cream but you
knew what one times one was that's
pretty good barely dude
i kept on saying 11.
you got something right and so like it
was embarrassing because you would
literally see the dumb kids with only
vanilla ice cream damn all the smart
kids would have just this crazy [__]
yeah but where are they now huh where
are they now diabetes one of them
actually is one of my really close
friends she's a lawyer she just bought
her house wow okay next anomaly
yeah they're all doing pretty well
[Laughter]
which honestly is a good depiction of
the real world right like if you work
hard you get rewarded things but i think
you should leave that in sports not in
math yes
yeah yeah yeah i think she assumed that
was smart because i was asian so she
just kind of left me alone i feel like
my teachers in high school like when it
came to math like i i only remembered
like one teacher that really cared if
you understood the math that we were
doing all the other teachers i've had
always made you feel like you were a
[__] idiot that you didn't get this
[__]
like you [__] [__] what's wrong with
you yeah like equals two dollars you
[__] monster
idiot yeah you know but the whole time
they also didn't like
help you with like really understand it
anymore you know they would just be like
oh you don't get it all right moving on
teachers are better now dude i think
they're starting to understand like how
to educate versus just doing the same
thing for every [__] kid because all
kids are different because i could
imagine you probably had like adhd and
[__] yeah i couldn't stop [__] i was
just always so just [__] squirmy but
they would think that we're
troublemakers but it's just like nah i
just you're just a kid yeah dude i feel
like math teachers specifically
our weird brand of teachers because like
my dude i had this guy mr mccoy and i
remember one class he just told he went
to go get tested
at the doctor's office he had malignant
melanoma the only reason i know that is
because he told us that he had cancer
and like we didn't learn math that day
he spent an hour and a half like
contemplating his life and like the fact
that he was like facing death possibly
13 year olds what's wrong with this guy
he was weird bro i remember one time too
you got an argument with this girl opal
like this black girl opal and opal was
cool charismatic but she was loud and
she would like start [__] sometimes
charismatic and then one time he like
started yelling at her and like they got
no yelling match and he's like yeah he's
like i love you oh paul i'm just here to
teach you and it like got really weird
and it was just like everyone was just
loving you he said i love you and it was
she
she stopped yelling
and it was just kind of like one it was
just everyone we were 13 but we all knew
that this [__] was weird
something was amiss yeah like we're
young but we could feel you i felt right
i don't know what is going on here but
it's [__] weird
i can smell it well this when we're
younger we always expect these people to
by the way you know these guys who were
teachers at the time if you look back at
it some of them were like 22 23 years
old yeah no he was older dude
okay yeah that's a crazy thing to say in
a class ever bro that class was crazy
especially in the heat of the moment
your response to somebody is i love you
that's why i love you
about this girl that [__] she picked
one of the pregnant teachers in the
stomach in my school oh my god bro i was
in the class uh next to it right and
this girl by the way was
from what i remember a cutie but she was
a badass like she she liked doing bad
[__] kicking pregnancy
i just i
somebody screaming in the other class
and you know us being who we are in our
school we just got the [__] up and left
and just the teacher's like where the
[__] is everybody going yeah i just got
outside and i literally see her being
dragged out of the class and she goes
i'll [__] you up i forgot her name but
she was she later on became my algebra
teacher but she wasn't at the time she
said i'll [__] you up and this lady is
full on like third trimester pregnant
and she [__] donkey kicks her right
in her stomach oh my god was the baby
okay yes the baby was okay but i
remember just watching
to the floor just holding her stomach
crying oh yo if that doesn't make you
quit being a teacher i don't know what
will what my school was not the best man
i don't know it doesn't sound like it it
was not like she legit kicked the
pregnant lady in the stomach and she was
so sweet to me she was sweet
i am yeah
dude my high school had some weird [__]
and the crazy thing is our class was the
nicer class the classes before us were
way worse yeah damn so it was like
during the time where like gang violence
was starting to dissipate so in our
class it wasn't so crazy but like two to
three years back like
our school used to have [__] gang
wars like they used to do uh school
lockdowns because people would start
shooting each other on campus like i
remember when i was
[__] was i uh that was before my cousin
moved out the neighborhood i think he
moved out when he was nine so i had to
be what six
so we were
i was at my cousin's house and this is
right across from the high school that i
used to go to called floor and high they
don't live there anymore
and we don't either but we were driving
out and this you know there's cops all
over the place and you could just hear
gunshots so it was a race war it was it
was like asians versus mexicans
and it was a full-on just [__]
shootout damn and so my my uncle at the
time it's uh abe's dad told everybody to
get down
because he he was uh he was a teacher at
folsom prison so he was like he told us
to get down in the middle of the vessel
we had to lay on the floor in the van
and he just reversed and [__] jetted
out of there yeah but that was our
school was weird dude back in the day
what side were you on bro huh i was a
part of the [__] la rasa baby
you're all confused
your eyes are too small to be on this
side
what you mean
[Laughter]
it was my freshman year and there was
like a standoff between the black kids
and the brown kids like in the middle of
the [__] like like quad
oh [__] and the helicopters were
circling bro like it was it was like i
remember it was the only year where [__]
was popping off like that between like
the black kids and the brown kids but
there was always some tension there's
always like a little bit after that but
after those kids graduated it kind of
chilled out our year thank god because
our year was actually pretty diverse but
it was actually crazy to see that [__]
because
the first time like a month at a new
school and you see these people about to
stand off and our teachers would tell
stories about how kids would would run
through class and and just beat the [__]
out of somebody in the class and then
dip out i hated the older clap dude i
remember i don't think i ever told this
because i'm so embarrassed but i'll tell
him now i don't give a [__] i don't know
why i never told the story i remember
one time and this happened to me and one
of my other friends too by the same dude
there's this white guy he we he was what
we used to call back in day a wiga he
was the one white dude in the group full
of black dudes and you know like the one
guy that's in a group of black dudes he
is trying so hard to be black it's
unreal this full legit was like six foot
three skinny as a [__] bean bowl he
actually kind of looked like machine gun
kelly i mean he always had the [__]
braids
like the cornrows in his hair oh well i
remember i'm just this kid at this am pm
i'm getting a slushie right
i've never been checked so hard in my
life this guy's like four years older
than me by the way i'm a freshman i'm 14
at the time so he's like
he got kicked out for sure but he would
have been like a freshman in college so
i remember i got i specifically remember
it was the coke slushie i got that [__]
right here filled it up to the top this
dude standing in front of me is like
give me your coke
and i'm like
who are you yeah
i'm like no and i'm moving past this
fool i [__] you don slaps me
in my face this little 13 year old fat
korean kid
i don't know what we're laughing
right wow and i look at him
i start
the [__] out of me and he steals my coke
slush and the [__] am pm guy just
watched the whole thing go down he
didn't do anything that's [__] up yeah
and i was just sitting there i just
remember i was like tearing up did he
give you another one huh did you let you
get another one no i just [__] cried
and i left and he just took my [__] it's
because you ran off to quake
you stuck around he would have given you
what is your fault
if i saw him till this day i would
remember his face damn because i know he
went to our house
dead bro
i don't think i was in high school at
the time i had to be around i was
obviously it was a while ago i think i
was like right in between the summer
before i went to high school but he
everybody knew who he was because he
also did this to one of my other buddies
too he's a coach
at the same amp so he would just
damn bro yeah so he also like slapped
like i think he smacked my other buddy
and he's like took cash from him but he
just took my coat and i just remember
tearing up because he was so much bigger
than me i could never do anything yeah
and it was him and all of a sudden all
of his homies outside just laughing at
me yeah you just wait till i get older
i'll kill you
yeah and you're a kid bro you're 13.
you're literally a kid like a child and
this grown ass man
but if you're gonna steal from somebody
oh you should do it from a small child
you know honestly yeah
you could have just touched your coke
and they would have been the same result
he open hand slapped you damn because i
didn't know what was going on he was
like give me your coke and i'm like
huh
i'm sure before that time that was one
of the only times someone has ever like
just
outright asked you for your [__] yeah
like stupid [__] amp and rafiq you
should have done some [__] [__] if he
didn't do [__] didn't even offer you
another one no he probably would have
made you pay for the other ones i know i
think you see repeat and they're like
yeah it's gonna be 550.
yeah you still got to pay dude
that was rough [__] guys well that wraps
up this episode of [__] genius
podcast stupid ass from fake [__] just
gave me a coke after i got slapped
but
if you guys can catch nick at nick the
air you can catch [__] pat patrick.t
dot riley and you can catch me at my
therapist's office while you're worrying
about this coke that will slap out of my
hands
uh genius brings every sundays at 12 p.m
and we'll see you all next time
it's funny you know imagine a little
david
little david approached the backpack
there's a backpack on yeah
with a little hat and [__] you know
shirt
with a little spinner on the back